does that feel Pearl
um I don't think that men and women
should be paid the same in sports
because they don't put on like they
don't make as much money
so like I play volleyball and basketball
in Europe and it it's unfortunate
because there's really not a lot of
opportunity in women's sports but I
don't know how you can complain when men
make more money at those Sports so if
you're a business and one business
brings in more money and one business
brings in less money of course you're
going to pay the business that make the
players for the business that makes more
money more it's just common sense like
they're not you don't see male only fans
models complaining because they don't
make the same as their female
counterparts but Ali equal pay for equal
work isn't this it's not equal work
because it's about the revenue so it's
about how much money are you bringing in
like who watches women's basketball here
I don't watch anything yeah okay are you
Sports guy huge Sports guy yeah okay and
you watch men's basketball right all the
time I I'm a female athlete I'm I'm
probably top like one percent in terms
of talent how far I've like taken well I
mean when you come count like people
because you're tall you're six foot but
like I have the opportunity to play pro
next year not a lot of people get get to
do that right and I can tell you that I
even in basketball which I play I don't
want to watch women's basketball why is
that even though you play it because
they're not they're not as good and I
mean that's not fun I I genuinely my
heart of soul like I'll probably turn
down that contract because it just isn't
enough money how much do you think the
contract will be the contract well I
could go to a terrible country like a
country where like no one lives it's
like this island in like Iceland or
something okay and make like three four
grand a month and not bad right Free
Housing but I'd be living like in the
middle of nowhere or I could go to
Germany and get like 500 a thousand a
month and I have nothing yeah and I have
friends that were like top 20 in the
ncaas like they played on those teams
for volleyball and like they they might
make 70 which which is decent but when
you think they're in the top like half a
point two five percent skill wise that's
like nothing so is this um Ali for you
is this equality for these sake of
equality did these women earn that no I
don't think they earned it this is why I
think feminism is a Female Supremacy
movement I'm just keeping it honest so
there are just some horrible Facts of
Life if you choose to look at them as
awful it can also be a benefit to be
physically a woman that's my perspective
on it but the reality is is that men are
faster they're stronger they can make
faster plays on the field where when you
watch female sports they're sluggish
they just move slower that's my that's
my perspective on it so they basically
whined enough to convince somebody to
pay them the same as men even though
they're not turning the same profit and
then what's the trickle-down effects of
this what what's the next area where
women are going to demand equal pay that
takes a sharp turn into communism and
redistribution of wealth I think it's
dangerous well and and you don't know
what that's going to do to the business
as a whole if you're like you you own a
business right and you know if you're
paying your employees too much and you
can't keep up like you're not making
enough money to pay them like that hurts
everybody so like why instead of instead
of whining about equal pay why don't we
work on putting on a better show the
same thing Coco do you think you think
that you the U.S soccer Federation
doesn't have money so that's why like
they should not give them to the women I
think there's enough money to go around
then why then why wouldn't they give it
to them they're giving it right now
aren't they but why did they have to
want like you don't okay so you can't
accept you're not going to accept an
offer that you're not worth so if they
didn't if they weren't cool with getting
paid that much they shouldn't have
accepted the initial offer
and so like now now you're gonna see
them like gassing up the price even
though I'm sure like the revenue
hasn't gone up God do you think they
deserve this ah good for them okay well
it doesn't hurt me let me let me just
I'm not a huge soccer fan but I can tell
you this I watched like male soccer in
Europe yeah
the the uh let me just tell me if this
changes your guys perspective at all the
U.S women's soccer team what are they
doing in that picture
they're winner Champion they won they're
actually winners right the men's team
freaking sucks sorry male soccer team so
because they won should they get paid
more well it depends or is it just
Revenue the bottom line yeah it should
be based on like I don't know the
numbers behind right so if this was a
situation where they really were
bringing in more money and they're
demanding a raise fine fine but what
happens more often than not even if it's
a losing men's team they tend to make
more than a woman's team and I'm a
female athlete I spent most of my life
playing sports like I I really care
about women's sports but I can't whine
and cry because more people attended the
men's basketball games in college than
ours like it just is what it is and we
can either work to improve the sport as
a whole or we can whine about our pay
and I'm just tired of these girls
whining about their pay instead of like
focus on your sport get better go ahead
you know they got beat by a high school
uh High School soccer team the men's the
women's team got beat by a men's soccer
team yes High School yes that's that's
actually something that occurred so
they're gonna get at this equal pay with
these male athletes that are you know
top tier but they can't even compete
with high schoolers so like I don't
think they earned it hmm so you're
bringing up valid points here
do you ever like I assume you're gonna
start running into women that are going
to start yelling at you pretty soon
[Music]
for the dirtiest dirtiest weirdest most
salacious comment what do you get I had
someone tell me that they were gonna do
witchcraft on me and my future baby
babies so that was a lot who was that
person I don't need her name but like
why did she say this what is she about I
don't know I think she got triggered by
my Tick Tock I mean whoever reads the
comment into every video is gonna have
some like if you post a puppy video
somebody's gonna say look at this point
was special this woman was special she
was like calling me on Instagram and
like trying to get her girlfriend to
call me too but obviously there's a low
value women that Coco doesn't associate
with you know what I mean so yeah the
weirdest thing out there I think I had
somebody send a letter to my school once
too a letter to your school I didn't
even know that yeah somebody Googled my
school and sent me a letter I mean it
was a creep what do you mean you're
school I was I was in college I just
graduated yeah
um all right wrapping this thing up
Natalia we're gonna take some questions
now and then after the questions
everyone will get their last two cents
and we'll wrap this thing up this has
been great okay I'm having a lot of fun
here Natalia do we have some super chats
yes you want so some of them are just
comments you want me just read the
question ones if there's some strong
comments throw it out there to the
atmosphere and let it out there but we
would like to answer some questions go
ahead so I'll start with the question
this is from Donovan sharp twenty
dollars we know Donovan nice help hello
Donovan
um it's for Coco and it says what do you
offer your boyfriend that you've never
given to any other man be specific
please don't use answers like it depends
or I'm not I don't have the Liberty to
say please answer the question what do
you offer what do I offer to my
boyfriend that you haven't offered to
any other boyfriend my wisdom as a 31
year old
I was never 31 before okay so your man's
getting your wisdom all right
um go ahead Natalia keep going let's see
it says the soccer deal this is from
blue pill unplugged five dollars it says
the soccer deal demonstration uh
demonstrates once again that men enable
women to being able to enjoy unequal
outcome but women will still trash talk
them men so that was a comment okay
um and then this one is from JG five
dollars he says what does Coco's
boyfriend do for work does she fear he's
just stringing her along play how
playing house
um why hasn't he married yet
I'm not going to say what he does for
work my my goal is not to put him in a
he's not a public person so like